δε δεν πρέπει να ζούνε τιςδικές τους πεπιθήσεις και τα δικά τους θέλο μέσα από
τι δωτω πατιον τους απλά να τα βοηθάνε να ιλοοποηγήσουν καια να καταφέρουν αυτά που
τα ίδια θέλουν και δια και αυτά πο αγαπον η ίδια παύλος ευχαριστώ πάρα πολύ
για αυτή τη υσηση που είχαμε σε ευχαριστώ και όσα μιράστηκε ε εγώ προσωπι κά
θα ευχυθώ ιπεσ ότι θα ακούσουν πολύ γονίς τα τα όσα είπες αλλά εγώ προσωπικά
έρχουμε να ακούσουν και οι αρμόδι φορείς τα όσα ίπες για να φτάσει όσον πιο
ψηλά γίνεται το ώρα μα σου αλλά και ο προβληματισμός που έχεις γιατί όταν ακούσω
παρά από να από έναν όλεν πιονίκη σίγουρα να δεντήμακάμια χώρα εγώ θα ευχηθώ να
τα ακούσουν σε ευχαριστούμε πολύ για όλες τις χαρές που μας έδωσες κάθε επιτυχία ατοποσιοκτώ
και ευχαριστώ ξανά ευχαριστώ παρααυλά και θα μετά φραζαλά παράνσε ισυγήσεις να ακούγεται πιο οραίο
να σε καλά υχαρι άι πολύπλι φίλες και φίλει άλλοναντναλλά ευχοτκάσει φτάσε στο τέλος του
θα τα πούμε την ερχούμε εβδωμάδα ευχαριστούμε και ταν πειν πάρχου μας κράτησαν και σήμερα
συντροφιά στη συζήση να έστε καλά θα ταξωνά πούμε